Yeah,
there are two possible ways to extend
your life with action that you take
today.
One is to do things that allow you to
maintain your health for a longer period
and the other is to act to hyphen that
referred so that the time when therapist
come along,
which can rejuvenate you and give you
another leaf of life,
come along in time for you.
Even if you are going downhill.
Those two things are additive,
so to speak.
They're independent criteria.
Now it turns out that the first
criteria,
and there's not much we can do unless of
course you are unusually for particular
age related problem like you know some
people come down with type two diabetes
and the 13th no drugs for that.
If you are the sort of normally healthy
person who has natural lifespan is going
to be her more than there is nothing to
speak of that we can do that will extend
your life by an appreciable amount or at
least that is proven to have jobs to be
able to do that.
So we have to look at number two and
number two,
the situation is completely different.
It doesn't matter who you are,
whether you're a scientist or a
broadcast or a journalist or a general
member of the public,
it doesn't matter who you are.
You can make a difference by
contributing to the enthusiasm and
society for this work,
by changing the mood of the fatty and
thereby changing the funding environment
so the work will be done more quickly.
Oh,
I personally,
for example,
don't get enough sleep because I'm
traveling all the time.
I'm on the road.
I'm trying to get this stuff to happen
and from a purely health point of view,
that's probably bad to me.
It's probably shortening my life,
but I'm pretty sure that I'm bringing
forward the day when the therapist will
arrive by a larger amount that I'm
filling in in my life,
but even in my own personal selfish
turned on probably winning.
And of course I'm not only doing it for
selfish reasons.
I'm doing it to save your life as well.